- Ma fille aurait eu 11 ans.
pour protéger l'identité
de la fratrie et entourée
de centaines de peluches,
a exprimé toute sa peine
etllllère.
- Jamais j'aurais pu penser
qu'un enfant...ààààààààààààààààs
des circonstances comme cela
- Pour elle, le système
a carrément abandonné sa fille,
qui était sous la garde de
son père et de sa belle-mère. aé
à plusieurs reprises la DPJ
des abus que subissait l'enfant.
- Qu
ton enfant a des bleus,
qu'on nie le fait qu'il y ait
des brûlures, que cette enfant-
qu'elle se fait maltraiter!
Je peux pas...LaLaLaLa mère de e
et ses grands-parents paternels
poursuivent
de services scolaires
du Val-des, , , , le CIUSSS de
l'Estrie-CHUS et personnellement
trois in
de services de la DPJ.
Ils rét t t t plus de
3,7 millions de dollars
en
Me VALÉRIE ASSOULINE, avocate,
t t t t de la famille et jeunese
- Ces intervenants ont ignoré
les drapeaux rouitititititititi,
alors que cette petite fille
appelait aux secours.
Elle avait le droit
à l'aen charge de la protéger,
elle avait le droit à la
dignité, le droit au secours
lorsque sa vie était en danger.
milieu scolaire d'avoir ignoré
la détresse de la fillette.
Malgré des signalement
d'enseignants, elle a été
déplore Me Assouline.
- Après tout ce qu'ils o
observé, ils ont recommandé
l'école à domicile, sachant
était en danger chez elle. On se
débarrasse pas d'un !!!!
- Un mois après son dernier jour
de fréquentation se,e,e,e,
elle est morte. Son père et
sa belle-mère
criminellement responsables
et sont prmememement incarcérés.
La grand-mère paternelle,
qui
pendant les premières années
dee,e,e,e, en veut
aux institutions.
- J'ai dénoncé mPePePePePePePePt
que c'est de gaité de coeur
qu'on fait ça? Non,
c'est pour les protéger.
parce qu'on gouvernement a pas
su faire cl l l l devait faire.
Centre de protection de
la jeunesse, qui veut dire :
à ce qu'ils ne souffrent pas,
ir à ce que cette enfant
reste sur Terre!
- Le CIUSSS et le Centre
erererervices scolaire ont refué
de commenter en raison de
Les procédures s'annoncent
longues. Les parties doivent
se présenter devant le tribunao.
Ici Marie-Hélène Rousseau,
Radio-Canada, Sherbrook